hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world
religious extremism versus global accord
can we teach the world to sing in
perfect harmony cybercrime who are the
villains and was it Christmas in July as
Amazon celebrated 20 years what makes a
perfect world Christians are told love
thy neighbor as thyself Islam has he is
not a Muslim who eats his fill while his
neighbor is starving and the Jewish
Torah tells us if the animal of a friend
requires unloading and an enemy's
loading you should first help your enemy
so then why are there so many religious
wars and conflicts fueled by religion in
a moment we speak to the US State
Department's ambassador-at-large for
International Religious Freedom that's
David Saperstein but first let me bring
in our usual guests Democrat commentator
Geoffrey Robertson standing by a new
york and the conservative commentator
armstrong williams is in washington so
much religion Jeffrey so little peace in
the world what's gone wrong very simple
no one's following the religion but it's
really that simple I mean if you look at
the Muslim extremism covering their
actions in the name of the Koran it's a
total miss reading of the Koran I mean
it's it's nothing but that these people
Isis for example are not religious
fanatics they're simply fanatics the
disguising their violence in the name of
some cause that simply has nothing to do
with Islam Armstrong are we being poorly
led by world leaders who don't get the
role of religion in people's lives you
know I i think it's it's so much so much
more significant in the profound this is
a centuries-old question that is uh
haunted us
uh since almost begin at a time what it
can kill Abel you can ask that question
you know people actually believe that
what they believe is the moral way and
will bring about better humanity and
bring about a better world there are
some Muslim extremists that believe that
the Western world is the detriment of
the world the fact that they embrace
same-sex marriages civil unions the fact
that their women are our get to do
things which in their culture women
should not do which you should hide them
and cover them there they have this
understanding of what righteousness is
that's why they feel that we're infidels
and that we pollute the world that's why
their values are not our values they
think the kind of values that we import
around the world is destroying the world
and so they feel that these infidels
should be destroyed they should be
straight from the face of the earth and
they believe this and it's real for us
in their interpretation of religion it's
just that their view of the world they
feel is more more more better and will
sustain the world more sore than ours
and what do you do you get rid of that
scourge that leadership the people that
represent the kind of value that is that
the files the world not uplifts it so
until we make people understand that all
human beings of them value everyone has
a right to their free will as long as it
does not infringe a devastate a corrupt
or hurt or harm other people they don't
understand that free will it's a choice
if you don't have a free will you're not
really free and so because people will
continue to believe this it's no
different then the Christians early on
and when they were leading sort of like
what we're seeing with the Muslim
extremist today it's just not it's not
going to change no different than
Crusaders it will continue and we will
continue have these conversations well
the US State Department's
ambassador-at-large for International
Religious Freedom is David Saperstein
he's fresh into the job David you've
taken on the most almighty job here
what's your number one task do you think
well it is the responsibility is to work
through our diplomatic or around the
world and our allies around the world to
strengthen religious freedom everywhere
everyone has
an internationally guaranteed right to
live with religious freedom to live in
accord with their religious conscience
limited only by their imposition of
their religion cannot bar others from
exercising the same right the same as
other fundamental rights protected by
international law and we're working with
countries to ease those laws practices
and regulations that impede religious
freedom for groups in their country and
in countries in which usually religious
minorities are subject to Social
hostility from other religious groups or
non-religious groups to encourage the
government to help change the climate
broaden religious tolerance and
understanding arm and protect those
minorities who are oppressed and does
your own faith in your own expertise in
your faith help you or hinder you in
that quest well I am I am part of the
Jewish community um we are amongst those
segments of humanity who has been most
subject to religious tolerant ah lurancy
a persecution often subject to religious
violence aimed at us we know all too
well what happens when those people
trying to live out their lives with
their countries in accordance with their
conscience are what happens when people
of good conscience stand idly by and
don't act to protect them and America
lives up to those values share by so
many of our faith that say we do not
stand idly by when we see people being
persecuted I'm very proud of what my
country has done in proud to work with a
coalition of a score of other countries
around the world who have made this a
priority concerning their own diplomacy
and foreign policy it's maybe too
simplistic to try and distill all the
world's ills into one particular region
but there is many people would say a
truism which argues if you fix Israel
Palestine a lot of the other conflicts
around the world would go away do you
agree with that
well in terms of just religious freedom
both Israel and Palestine gave the
significant amount of religious freedom
law Israel it's one of the few areas in
the region where the Christian community
for example has grown in numbers rather
than shrunken I in numbers I i think
that the problems of religious freedom
go far beyond the israel-palestinian
conflict and they cut across the entire
global community and we will best
address those when we encourage the
community of nations to stand up and to
secure for all their citizens that right
enshrined in the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights Jeffrey you say the
problem might be a we are encouraging
everyone to be free to follow their
religion but only the religion we like
no I don't I don't think that's quite it
i mean if you think back and an
Armstrong alluded to the Crusades it's
often said I don't know if it's true but
I suppose it is that more people have
been murdered in the name of religion
than anything else throughout history
but I just don't know I mean I look at
this job that the david has and I I wish
you well David I really hope you're
successful but I don't actually know
what you're supposed to do and let me
ask you I have two questions one the
first is what's the history of this
position are you the first one you're
the first investment it was created by
the International Religious Freedom Act
in the past in 1998 I am the fourth
person to hold this title arm and had to
have these responsibilities and we are
making a difference in many areas across
the globe coalition's in areas of the
Muslim world in the southern hemisphere
and certainly confronting problems in
the in Europe and North America there
are many places where we're making
progress but it is a daunting challenge
well I suppose it is i mean it's much
like waving the flag and motherhood and
apple pie and all that everybody should
be in favor of it I just don't know what
you're going to accomplish because I
think you're preaching to the choir and
I don't say this hostile I mean I I wish
you well I hope you changed the world
and and everybody does sing in harmony
like the old coke commercial used to say
but I just don't
get it I don't know what you're supposed
to do or what that post is ever
accomplished can you tell me one thing
for instance in Europe or North America
that's changed well we don't deal with
the United States and there aren't that
many problems and in terms of the
Western Hemisphere um in Europe we
obviously have been working closely with
the OSCE to help think about the Soviet
Jewry movement here and the ability of
the United States together with
like-minded countries to make a
significant difference that led to
easing of a number of restrictions in I
in Russia and the release of many people
we get religious prisoners out prisoners
of conscience across the globe and we
work with countries to change policies
and you can look from Sri Lanka to cut
other countries across the globe where
we've seen improvements now that are
very encouraging that's great the longer
leash Alex this discussion absolutely
I'm strong thank you look I think what
mr. dr. Saperstein what he does is
almost invisible because what he has to
do is change hearts and behavior how do
you get people in the world to believe
that because you feel your wife is
committing adultery she's looking at a
man the wrong way you have a right to be
hit her under stone her do we respect
that's the way of the Muslim faith and
do we have a right to judge that no
different than people try to judge our
prison the fact that we have people in
prison and we have the death penalty in
the United States people see that as a
human right violation but that is a part
of who we are a part of our value system
when you commit these heinous crimes you
should be put to death there are all
kinds of things in the world and how
even in as mr. Saperstein discussed
Israel how can you begin to talk about
the Palestinians in the Middle East
where they don't even see Jews as being
human they want to see them disappear in
the sea you hear the caller Khomeini
talking about depth of Jews and death to
America how do you get them to value
human beings you may not agree with them
you may not like their positions but how
can you say that humanity is less and
devalue just because you disagree with
them v Emily I think miss dr. Saperstein
has a tough task
but someone has to do it by changing
hearts and really believe it at all
human beings have value so exam yeah we
begin by trying to work with countries
across the globe about the curricula of
both religious schools and the non
religious schools in those countries to
enhance religious tolerance or a number
of places we're making significant
progress we work with the international
community to deal with this on a legal
basis to show really as opposed to
blasphemy laws that there are ways
without criminalizing um for freedom of
expression about religious issues that
people have heartfelt differences they
can address religious tensions and
defamation of religion we help with
allies in the Muslim world including the
support of the OIC to pass the
resolution 1618 at the you now at the
United Nations that makes that a
worldwide goal and we know that many
countries where blasphemy laws still
exists common people are brutally
punished for their religious expressions
um but in many areas around the world
where people really are looking at
different approaches and are turning
away from the criminal justice system as
a way to resolve religious differences
in conflicts that may exist one of the
things I think you face a challenge from
David Saperstein is perhaps because you
come from you are an American you come
from America doesn't that bring an awful
lot of baggage to your job well but
these human rights are in those
international covenants in our norms
accepted by the whole world and of
course on any one of those rights in the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
their areas around the world specific
countries in every hemisphere every
continent the tues bed does better in
some do much worse and we are constantly
on Human Rights trying to encourage
change in some policies to alleviate
oppression of human rights that's an
international challenge and we're
working with countries across the globe
from the Muslim world the country's
predominantly Hindu and Buddhist to try
and achieve those goals so this is not
just a Western invention these are
universal norms and it is a fundamental
right of every person
matter where they live no matter what
their religion to live their life safely
army in accordance with their conscience
both individually and with those who
share their faith that fundamental right
might be agreed by many people Armstrong
but it's not a reality in for many
people in many countries that's the
problem generally it will it will never
be a reality and I think dr. Saperstein
and Jeffrey understands that but it
doesn't mean it doesn't preclude you but
not pursuing the goal because if dr.
Saperstein can say change one heart one
liter you know that can you imagine the
amount of power that some leaders can
have where hundreds of thousands people
would live and spurs die where they're
willing to change the rules while you
value life you come up with another
punishment instead of death and the
harsh punishments that they have in
place so I think it's like a
thousand-mile journey dr. Saperstein is
taking baby steps but this is a baby
step arena that he's in and you have no
idea the impact he has until time
reveals it so he must go forward with
his mission and Jeffrey do you wish him
well in this endeavor do you think it's
a certain waste of government money no
no I certainly do and I was gonna I was
going to mention that Armstrong had
taken too far in suggesting that David
could somehow influence the Iranian
ayatollahs but he's absolutely right the
long march begins with baby steps and I
had never heard of this office before
David I wish you all the luck in the
world because what you're doing is
absolutely right and every penny that
American taxpayers are spending to get
this mission accomplished is money well
spent Godspeed and just just to throw a
little curveball david saperstein it you
right at the close of our conversation
the nuclear talks guys have managed to
get a new basis with Iran we discussed
that on this program before would you
try and go there and talk about
religious freedoms in Iran to would that
be one of your destinations I'd be
talking about religious freedom anywhere
that I could it's a message needed
desperately in Iran that we have named
as one of that small group of countries
of particular concern where there are
systemic egregious ongoing persecution
so these are daunting challenges in
particularly in countries like Iran had
the sole limit
on the fundamental right of people to
live out their lives in accordance with
their religious conscience on the Pew
poll says 75 percent of the world's
population lives in countries that have
significant restrictions on religious
freedom it may be if they're the
majority there they may not feel it but
others in their country do and we're
working with every country across the
globe to try and get them to ease those
restrictions to allow religious freedom
to flourish it makes for a more stable
country a more just country on in a
world in which freedom can really
flourish david saperstein we thank you
for joining us on the program today
a reminder you can catch up with Sky
News debate on Apple TV Roku on catch up
and of course on Sky News calm / US
cyber security needs to up its game
Hillary Clinton has accused China of
trying to hack into everything that
doesn't move in America and earlier this
month the New York Stock Exchange and
the Wall Street Journal were brought
down by computer systems failures well
Tim EADS is the chief executive of V
armor one of the world's leading cyber
security companies and as you can see
he's with us Timmy it's what's the
biggest challenge facing business today
it's an amazing time to be in data data
center security so the biggest challenge
is going on today is the traditional
companies are trying to keep up with the
new companies so the traditional hotel
chains are trying to keep up with these
newcomers like air B&B and as they try
to transform that their data centers to
become more digital you know you got to
become secure as you go agile so it's
it's a it's a tough time because you
can't see the traffic so so the big
challenges you've got to transform your
data center to get competitive but you
going to make it secure at the same time
now we had a story here in the UK it
probably resonated in America as well
about a dating site this was actually
for people who wanted to commit adultery
but all their data may well be released
onto the world in the net in the coming
days there must be other stuff going on
though in the business to business space
which you probably know about and we
don't now how bad is the problem how
frequent are serious breakdowns of big
systems yeah so that particular breach
is just another example of cyber ransom
right so cyber answer whether it's you
know movie studio or government or
social site or a dating site you know
it's common its daily some of which you
hear about some of which you don't and
what you know it's really amazing it's
quite frustrating at certain times
because people are buying old products
you know sometimes 20 year old products
at least 10 year old products mostly to
try and protect modern data centers in
modern applications so if you think
about it is you're trying to buy old
products to sort of new Wars it just
doesn't work so it's [ __ ] the IT guy is
that what you're saying no it's lovely
t guy the IT guy need some help I mean
this is a time where he should be
reaching out and reaching up he's got
more board access than ever before
pulling more access to money than ever
before and the read the nice thing about
it is things used to be appliances and
just all pieces of metal now you can do
things in the software so if you can
help him out he can deploy things
relatively quickly and more efficiently
so love the IT guy but give him given
the opportunity to be heard let's bring
in Geoffrey Robinson in New York and
Armstrong Williams in Washington
Armstrong you got multi-million pound
businesses around the world you must be
nervous about this kind of cyber attack
you know this is a truly a fascinating
and intriguing discussion because Tim
here in the United States well as the
host just mentioned a presidential
candidate Hillary Clinton is speaking
out on this issue but while she speaks
out on this issue Tim the president is
not willing to blame China or include
China in the conversation about the hack
of the office of personnel management
but we call it here in the United States
other people's mail and the reason why
the United States doesn't want to do
that is because it's quite curious
contemp they don't want to necessarily
bring China into the fold because it
would put them in the spotlight of their
own cyber activity and the fact is how
they were able to know for certain that
China was the one who was responsible
for that hacking and also the United
States um begrudgingly think about this
begrudgingly on the people within the
investigative units that are responsible
for investigating this begrudgingly
admire China what for what they were
able to do because in the United States
they are trying to do the same you know
it's a great point so it's actually a
very interesting point too so here's the
thing there's no doubt that the US and
the UK and some of the parts of the
Western world have incredibly advanced
cyber weapons and deep into your
infrastructure around the world but the
challenge is if your main parameters of
your national infrastructure imparts the
national infrastructure and parts of the
large kind of core enterprises I
a front of only made of Swiss cheese are
you full of holes how hard you want to
throw stone because you know the fight
back is could be worse when 43 to
forty-nine percent of all US companies
were breached last year you know how
hard you want to throw that stone yeah
you can have the greatest weapons yeah
you don't want them to be revealed but
you know you have to shore up your own
footing first so one of the things that
you know President Obama is doing is
pushing along this Federation capability
to share information threats and stuff
that's a good step it's a first step
it's nowhere near enough right because
if you think about it the defense used
to be land sea and air now it's land sea
air and cyber so you've got to
adequately spend that cyber dollar in
two ways offense and defense and if your
offense is heavily invested in which is
great you still need a good defense and
right now you know clearly you're not
just the government but also you know
the u.s. enterprises are you know for
the holes Geoffrey you've written about
criminality in several tomes is it
always just criminals who are driving
this or do you think its international
cyber warfare is also an issue to the
answer to that question is yes
international cyber warfare and playing
chess cyber chess with other countries
is certainly part of it the the idea of
corporate spying is huge it's a
multi-billion dollar industry to find
out you know the soft drink manufacturer
wants to find out the contracts of the
competitors competing software a soft
drink manufacturer I mean everybody's
trying to get up on everybody else but
there's something that hasn't been
raised that I found in covering this
both in the City of London and on Wall
Street writing about cyber fraud is that
a number of businesses are simply in
denial about this and two-thirds it's a
shocking figure with two-thirds of all
cyber frauds in the city and in Wall
Street go unreported to the police why
because the Chairman doesn't want of the
board to know more about it they don't
want the stockholders to know they don't
want the public to know they don't want
to port
it'll blow up and make the customers
think that they're vulnerable by keeping
their money in the back it's a horrible
situation so they just want to make it
go away they will pay whatever they have
to pay and then bolster up their
fortress to make sure it doesn't happen
again it's very sure now it is well
Jeffrey don't scale enough can we just
ask Tim a question if they're not scared
enough now because they let me see if we
can worry them into action shall we
because Tim one of the points you've
been making is that it's not just may be
the lone wolf hacker now this is very
sophisticated and it sort of links into
the world of terror doesn't it oh
absolutely major institutions are being
held to ransom by effectively cyber
terrorists absolutely right but you know
the gentleman's point is dead on is that
you bad guys are getting into networks
they're moving around and that one of
the reasons why you know they they are
scared to come out and tell people
what's going on is because they don't
know where they've gone right I mean
when you get into a network but most
enterprises can't see traffic inside
their data center and if you can't see
it you can't protect it and you know
there's a very fine line as you start to
look you know the difference between
legitimate network traffic and criminal
network traffic because the criminal
tries to blend in so they're very very
sophisticated they get in and they
spread and when they're in you in your
network you might it's like whack-a-mole
you might get them in one corner but the
pop-up into another so disclosing that
they're in is interesting it's like the
OPM breach the first time the OPM breach
came out was like four million you know
users within went to 18 I think it ended
up in this in the 30s million users
because they don't know where they got
in and they don't know how far they got
so you know they do get in they do move
around people can't see the traffic and
it's a major problem and you know ransom
is just one aspect i mean you know
obviously they're after your
intellectual property and you have to
change the way that you can see the
traffic and you have to take the
protection which used to be just at the
perimeter and put it next to the assets
that you want to protect okay we better
leave it there for today Timmy's thank
you very much indeed thank you
the garage based online bookstore which
began as Cadabra has just celebrated its
20th birthday we know it as Amazon well
let's bring in Geoffrey Robinson and
Armstrong Williams I bet you're both
users Armstrong what's the last thing
you got from the Amazon boys Oh as the
as the is the last thing that I've
market it to the Amazon board I mean
amazon is just it's just so many things
and everywhere it's only going to grow
in strength and I mean it's just the
best example of what entrepreneurship
the world has known Geoffrey Robinson is
there nothing they won't sell you well
there's nothing that you can sell them
as well I mean I sell I some books on
Amazon and it's created a whole world of
ebooks so Amazon in that sense is great
but it's also Godzilla remember the old
Japanese monster movie it's Godzilla
it's killed off the book storage in
North America it is horrible if you are
a supplier because they are known to
take your idea and then make it
themselves and can push you out there
really nasty to their employees they're
very strict on employees time and
salaries and whatnot so there's this
great side that it's very convenient to
buy a book and now the deliver the book
in New York the same day or anything
else that they have their opening stores
that you can go pick up the stuff but in
the same time they are they are also
what happens with capitalism run wire
yeah they're going to drone deliveries
have you done that yet term I'm strong
you know I actually have it wrong so
I'll let you figure out the rest ok
thank you guys for being with us once
more time as well Armstrong and Jeffrey
and that's it for this edition of the
debate you can continue watching sky
news on apple TV on roku on catch up and
of course at Sky News calm until next
time goodbye